ja also die Atomkraftwerke über den
Jahres 11 Jahre Ende hinaus zu betreiben
das ist ein bisschen so als würde man
jetzt sich denken ich mache eine Fahrt
mit meiner mit der Bahnfahrt schön in
Urlaub ach auf den letzten Drücker sage
ich doch nämlich noch das Auto hat zwar
keinen TÜV war vor 13 Jahren das letzte
Mal zur Inspektion will auch keiner
versichern und der Motor hat Risse aber
ich mache es trotzdem fahr auf der
Autobahn 3 Monate lang mit 180 das
Risiko dass dadurch entsteht das das
tragen wir alle und das ist das Problem
was wir jetzt sehen als Anti
akaw-bewegung als atomkritische
Medizinerinnen und Mediziner das von
einigen Seiten eine Lösung für die
Energiekrise versprochen wird eine
einfache Lösung vermeintlich einfach die
die gesundheitlichen die ökologischen
und auch die Sicherheitsrisiken
eigentlich außen vor lässt und einfacher
erscheint als sie tatsächlich ist
bedenkt man die Probleme die ISA Isa 2
und lecker Westheim 2 jetzt noch haben
angesichts der ventilschäden in Isar und
angesichts der rissigen Rohre in
Neckarwestheim also da ist das letzte
Wort noch nicht gesprochen ob das so
einfach geht die weiter betreiben zu
lassen oder ob doch da Reparaturen dem
Ganzen eine Schippe schlagen
ist auch so dass es gefährlich ist es
jetzt weiterlaufen lassen ich sehe das
anders
ökonomisch würde man erst einmal sagen
in einer so schweren Krise wie diese
Energiekrise geht es darum dass Angebot
auszuweiten um sich von nicht weiter von
diesem Gaspreis abhängig zu machen und
Angebot erweitern heißt alles was wir an
Energiequellen haben nutzen und dazu
gehört die Atomenergie auch deswegen
weil es eine heimische Energie ist da
müssen wir nicht extra in den vorderen
Orient pilgern zu starten die nicht
minder autoritär sind wie Russland oder
vielleicht ein bisschen weniger
aggressiv sind sondern wir haben eine
eigene Energieform sie ist ökologisch
klimamäßig das sauberste was mir haben
und sie ist aber auch am wenigsten
riskant das ist der Punkt wo ich Ihnen
am meisten widersprechen würde ich habe
mir heute weil ich wusste dass sie
kommen angeschaut Max rosa ist ein
Mensch in Oxford aber world in data
heißt das der verlässliche Statistik und
er hat aufgemacht eine Reihenfolge der
hört sich ein bisschen zynisch an der
Todesfälle pro Terra
wattstunde und da steht ganz oben die
Kohle als nächstes kommt das Öl dann
kommt das natural gas dann kommt sogar
der Wind und dann erst kommt also bei
der Kohle sind wir 25 Todesfälle auf
diese terrorarbeitsstunde und beim Atom
sind es
0,03 und er hat große Zahlen sowohl für
Tschernobyl wie auch für Fukushima ein
also man kann ihn nicht vorwerfen dass
er an der Stelle minimiert hat sondern
er hat das Risiko dieser beiden aber
mehr haben wir gar nicht im Vergleich zu
viel also man muss auch da abwägen alles
ist riskant im Leben aber relativ ist
die Atomenergie die am wenigsten riskant
haben wir abgewogen als Gesellschaft
zweimal in den letzten Jahren haben wir
einen breiten gesellschaftlichen Konsens
was wir in Deutschland Risiko eine soll
ein Sonderweg machen und sie sagen wir
müssen nicht in vorigen Orient der Uran
der benutzt wird das kommt natürlich aus
dem Niger das kommt aus Kasachstan also
wir müssen natürlich das Importieren das
ist keine heimische wir produzieren kein
Uran mehr seit 1990 und man muss einfach
sagen dass die Atomkraftwerke jetzt die
Gaskrise lösen das stimmt einfach nicht
wir haben keinen Strom Mengenproblem wir
haben ein netzstabilitätsproblem im
nächsten Jahr Strom
Preisproblem haben aber durch das was
wir married order nennen dass wir wir
haben einen so teuren Strompreis weil
wir Gas verstromen müssen und das
könnten wir zurückfahren
die teuerste Stromproduktion die es
überhaupt nur gibt aber was geht das ist
wirklich ein bunter Strauß an Argumenten
das finde ich toll weil es eigentlich
alles miteinander vermischt es gibt kein
Argument was möchte ich sagen vorsichtig
ausgedruckt dann vielleicht doch lustig
genug ist um genannt zu werden also ihr
Beispiel mit dem TÜV und dem Auto das
ist ja nun wirklich das Falscheste was
man machen kann denn der TÜV SÜD hat ja
erst kürzlich bestätigt dass es
überhaupt kein Problem ist diese
Kernkraftwerke länger laufen zu lassen
und er hat noch mal auch bestätigt dass
es bei den Kernkraftwerken die es hier
in Deutschland geht sich um die
sichersten Handel selbst die die schon
abgeschaltet wurden Ende 21 die wir auf
der Welt haben alle zehn Jahre also ist
eine Sicherheitsüberprüfung stattfinden
aber fand 2009 vor aber
glauben sie sollte 2019 wieder
stattfinden ist verschoben worden wegen
des atomaus
sie wissen dass die im laufenden
Verfahren sind und sie wissen auch dass
ein Auto was nicht nach zwei Jahren beim
TÜV gewesen sondern vielleicht nach
zweieinhalb auch nicht automatisch
auseinander fällt wir wissen nicht was
da passiert ist ja keine Saft einlaufen
was hätten sie denn eigentlich gewonnen
wenn wir darüber reden wenn diese drei
Kernkraftwerke abgeschaltet werden aber
auf der Welt um uns herum die alte
älteren Meiler weiterlaufen und zusätz
sich immer neue meiner gebaut werden was
genau gewinnt eigentlich Deutschland und
dritter Punkt wird den machen darf
wir schalten hier im Land ich weiß wie
viel wie viel Pools in diesem Land
werden mit Gas beheizt 20.000 vielleicht
bundesweit die werden abgeschaltet weil
es offenbar ein Problem mit der
Gasversorgung gibt ich habe immer gehört
dass es knapp das wird aber zur
Stromproduktion auch benutzt ganz
entscheidend also wenn wir da die
Kernkraftwerke rausnehmen dann müssten
wir entweder zusätzlich diese Lücke von
rund 7 bis 8 Prozent die Kernkraftwerke
zur Stromproduktion beitragen mit Gas
auffüllen kann man machen haben wir
gerade wenig oder mit Kohle und unser
Eindruck war doch bisher glaube ich
richtig das genau die Kohle das Problem
ist deswegen wird ja zum Beispiel der
Kohleausstieg noch mal vorgezogen auf
2030 weil ganz ganz viel CO2 Luft geht
deswegen die Argumente die kommen die
sind so unterschiedlich aber sie sind
alle bemüht aber immer dieses Argument
entweder fossile oder Atomen
Realität wir haben in Deutschland einen
Konsens aber nein wir haben
aufgebrochen das stimmt überhaupt nicht
die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung ist
eindeutig für längere Laufzeiten eine
und eine ganz kurz und die Frage muss
erlaubt sein wenn Sie das sagen wir
müssen auf erneuerbare Energien setzen
sagen Sie doch mal wie das im Winter
funktionieren soll in diesem Winter und
im nächsten wo sehen Sie denn die
Mehrheit für Laufzeiten wenn wir gerade
eine große Wahl hatten Niedersachsen wo
es um das AKW Emsland geht und alle
politische Parteien hast du einen und
immer gemacht haben und ganz klar die
Parteien die für den Atomausstieg zum
Jahresende waren gewonnen haben und die
Parteien die gesagt haben wir müssen und
das ist das wichtigste Thema für uns die
Atomkraftwerke weiter betreiben
eine Partei die übrigens gar nicht für
Klimaschutz ist die nicht mehr das
Pariser Klimaabkommen anerkennt ist die
AFD und meines Wissens nach hat die
Niedersachsen nicht ganz schlecht
abgeschnitten bei der Wahl ja jetzt muss
man natürlich gucken dass es
verschiedene Ursachen hat die AFD
Totschlagargument dass alle Bürger in
Niedersachsen nur das wollen sie meinen
also die Erfolge nein aber ich sehe ich
ich sehe einfach dass wir in stärksten
gerade eine Wahl hatten die zum Großteil
auch um das Atomthema ging wo eine ganz
andere Entscheidung getroffen wird und
jetzt wird auf Bundesebene gesagt ihr
wollt nicht das Emsland weiterläuft eure
Regierung will nicht dass Emsland
weiterläuft trotzdem machen wir das und
das das Perfide an der ganzen Sache
übertreiben
über ein einzelnes Atomkraftwerk und ich
glaube auch nicht dass die Anti
akw-bewegung sich einen Gefallen tut
jetzt mit so einem bunten Strauß an
Argumenten zu kommen
ihr Sicherheits ihre Sicherheitsbedenken
wie sie jetzt geäußert haben die sind ja
für eine sehr spezifische Situation und
vor der Klammer steht ja sowieso
Atomkraftwerke laufen nur weiter solange
sie von den Aufsichtsbehörden auch
genehmigt werden wenn das nicht der Fall
ist wenn sie natürlich abgeschaltet
nein das das soll hoffentlich keine
politische Entscheidungen von der
Entscheidung sie können ja politisch
vereinbaren wenn diese Bedingung erfüllt
ist dann dass wir sie weiterlaufen
genauso können Sie sagen wenn ihr kein
Personal mehr habt müssen wir natürlich
die Atomkraftwerke schließen logisch
aber weniger Personal habt dann lassen
wir sie weiterlaufen es wird aber ein
Argument nach dem anderen nicht
genehmigungsfähig jetzt kommt in
Niedersachsen Wahl und so weiter das
macht die gesamte Position meines
Erachtens argumentativ immer schwächer
weil sie so situativ mit Einzelaspekten
kommt es gibt wenn Sie grundsätzlich
weiterhin sagen wir wollen kein
Atomkraft und dabei bleibt es nach ihrer
Ansicht dann würde ich das ja noch
nachvollziehen können aber dieses
sozusagen unterfüttern mit lauter
Argumenten die eigentlich nichts tragen
denn wir reden ja hier genau genommen
nicht über die Frage ob jetzt noch mal
ein einzelnes Atomkraftwerk dreieinhalb
Monate länger laufen soll oder ob die
anderen jetzt statt in diesem
streckt ja genau dem schrecklich laufen
oder in die Notreserve gehen das sind ja
wirklich gegeben die Herausforderung von
die wir jetzt stehen und zwar nicht nur
im nächsten Winter sondern für die
nächsten 10 bis 15 Jahre wirkliche PT
testen das heißt du musst jetzt ja
grundsätzlich darüber nachdenken wollen
wir weiterhin auf diese Technologie
setzen ja oder nein aber da muss man
doch jetzt einfach sagen wir haben doch
die Situation dass wir in den nächsten
Monaten das sagt der Stress das ganz
klar im Worst Case-Szenario die wird die
die Flüsse sind haben wir nicht genug
Wasser frankreich hat kein
Atomkraftwerke laufen Polen liefert
nicht und kein Gas dann haben wir drei
bis zwölf Stunden im Februar keinen
Strom das ist das Worst Case Szenario
die großen alu-hütten müssen drei bis
zwölf Stunden runtergefahren werden die
Lösung ist wir lassen Atomkraftwerke
vier Monate weiter laufen dadurch
reduziert sich diese Zeit auf null bis
eine Stunde darüber reden wir und
deswegen wird ab November das
Atomkraftwerk Isa 2 runtergefahren damit
es weniger Strom produziert und dafür
länger produziert keine
kommen
wenn sie die Sicherheitsbedenken hätten
dann müssten sie doch auch sagen es gibt
auch keine Verlängerung um drei Monate
dann werden die jetzt sofort abgeschafft
genau das habe ich das wollen sie doch
und ich muss auch sagen das ist ja
die Entscheidung des
Verwaltungsgerichtshofs in Mannheim der
am 14 Dezember darüber entscheidet
überhaupt weiter betrieben werden kann
oder nicht einmal zu dieser Entscheidung
die kommen wir einmal zu dieser
Entscheidung die jetzt schon ganz oft
angesprochen wurde denn es wurde ja das
erste Mal seit Adenauer die
Richtlinienkompetenz davon Gebrauch
gemacht und da ist ja auch von Herr
Scholz hat das denn nicht vielleicht die
prekäre Lage einfach in der man sich
auch befindet gezeigt wenn man diese
Entscheidung macht Theater Donner ist
doch alles politische Symbolik sie haben
es ja gerade gesagt ob die jetzt vier
Monate weiterlaufen oder nicht ändert
nichts an der Problematik das löst kein
Problem es ist politisches ja auf dem
Preis aus wird aber auch das was niemand
behauptet niemand sagt wenn wir
Atomkraftwerke da weiterlaufen lassen
haben wir unser Energieproblem gelöst
das sagt keiner ich kenne jedenfalls
niemanden der das ernsthaft behaupten
würde sondern was gesagt wird ist es ist
ein Baustein in unserer zukünftigen
Energiestrategie und die müssen wir
ändern weil die die wir bislang gefahren
haben sich so nicht mehr realisieren
also auch unfair zu unterstellen
diejenigen die bereit sind weiter auf
die Atomkraft zu setzen würden damit
suggerieren dann werden unsere sonstigen
Probleme auch alle gelöst das sind sie
natürlich nicht ihr eigenes Instituts
nennt doch Atomenergie eine
konfliktreiche riskante und mit unserem
Energiesystem nicht kompatible
Energieform also langfristig ist das
falsch verstanden
langfristig ist Atomenergie kann sich
das Deutschland an als einziges Land mit
Österreich diese noch radikaler diesen
Sonderweg geht hat der Rest der Welt
sind die einfach vernagelt haben die
nicht begriffen aus ihrer Sicht mir
riskantes ist oder warum machen alle
anderen das inklusive Finnland und den
Grünen die dort neue Atomkraftwerke
bauen also korrigieren Sie mich wenn ich
falsch liege die 85% der Staaten der
Welt haben keine Atomenergie und das hat
einen guten Grund denn die Atomenergie
existiert praktisch nur in den Ländern
mit Atomwaffen und deren Verbündeten
weil Atomwaffen oder Atomen von Anbeginn
des Atomzeitalters miteinander verknüpft
ist unsere angstkultur daher kommt die
Angst vor der atomrosenindustrie aber
die großen völlig klar nachgewiesen dass
es genau aus dieser Angst entstanden
Industrienationen und das wissen wir
auch und die sind ja auch für den
Wohlstand erstmal für ihre Bevölkerung
aber auch für Teil des Wohlstands auf
der Welt verantwortlich setzen alle auf
atomenergien selbst Japan fängt wieder
an über den Neubau nachzudenken mich
würde trotzdem eins interessieren da
wundert mich auch ihre Argumentation hat
mich wundert sie eigentlich nicht wie
kann es eigentlich sein dass sie sagen
weil in Frankreich die Kernkraftwerke
nicht funktionieren was sie doch wollen
ist doch nichts anderes als hier drei
abzuschalten in der Hoffnung dass in
Frankreich die älteren Dinger alle
wieder laufen das aber natürlich anders
geht's doch gar nicht Frankreich die
Atomkraftwerke eingeschaltet werden viel
schwieriger und wie erklären sie sich
eigentlich dass in Frankreich der
CO2-Ausstoß pro Kopf halb so hoch ist
wie in Deutschland weil die weniger
Kohlekraftwerke haben richtig und was
haben sie Atomkraftwerk und erzählen Sie
mir den dritten Punkt noch mal wie
kommen wir in diesem und im nächsten
Winter ohne
Kohlekraft und ohne Kernkraft durch den
Winter was Frankreich in 20 Jahren macht
wir reden doch
wir reden jetzt mal über ein Problem was
jetzt zu lösen ist und wir können uns
ganz viel vor wir liefern nach
Frankreich Strom nicht Frankreich
aber reden wir doch bitte jetzt mal und
dann werde ich wenn ich es toll wenn Sie
die Frage beantworten könnte weil die
ist konkret was machen wir mit der Lücke
die wir dann hätten in einer Zeit in der
die Sonne relativ kurz scheint und
möglicherweise Wind auch nicht weht wie
füllen wir die Lücke auf die wenn wir
die Atomkraft rausnehmen dann gedeckt
werden haben sie den Stresstest gelesen
es geht nicht und falls doch mal die
Antwort wo der Wind nicht weht es geht
um Zeiten wo der Wind zu viel weht wir
haben ja ein Überangebot an Strom im
Netz das ist das Problem es gibt die
dunkelflaut das wissen Sie auch wissen
Sie ganz genau sie kennen das doch alles
aber Verhalten sie doch die Zuschauer
nicht für blöd sagen Sie doch mal wie
das Problem gelöst habe ich gerade
gesagt
abschalten für 12 Stunden
was genau Ihre Praxis oder was wollen
sie auf
für ein paar Stunden
Großverbraucher also
Industrieunternehmen ja aber wie stellen
sich das vor die Menschen
wie stelle ich mir das vor es ist ein
Produktion die Aluminium produziert die
muss nicht die ganze Nacht produzieren
da kann man einen Deal machen und das
ist ja Usus das wird tagtäglich in
unsere Energie-System gemacht ja das
heißt es muss nicht immer nur mehr mehr
aber genau diesen Dielen Stromkunden
bezahlen weil diejenigen den jetzt der
Strom abgeschaltet wird die werden
natürlich
entscheideanlage betreibt er ein
Windkraftwerk betreibt kennt das wenn es
ein Problem im Netz gibt dann wird man
abgeschaltet aber das heißt sie würden
für das Gemeinwohl die Frage fand ich
gerade gar nicht so blöd sie würden für
einen gemeinsam
ihre Praxis dann ein paar Stunden am Tag
schließen weil Industrieunternehmen
würden sie machen fürs Gemeinwohl glaube
wir müssen alle diesen Winter und das
sehe ich in den Schulen das sehe ich in
den Ministerien das sehe ich auch in den
Arztpraxen und Krankenhäusern Energie
sparen das ist doch völlig völlig klar
was ich sagen will ist die Netzbetreiber
haben Pläne und Strategien wie Sie mit
dieser Situation umgehen die Klagen
nicht die sagen nicht machen keine Angst
vor Blackout weil die wissen wir kommen
damit klar und das Hauptproblem noch
einmal ist eine Überproduktion von Strom
in Norddeutschland bei gleichzeitig
hoher
Stromnutzung in Süddeutschland und an
beiden kann man drehen gerade schon was
zum Beispiel bei E.ON oder auch anderen
los ist also sie haben extra
psychologisch schon angestellt weil die
Verkäufer gar nicht mehr wissen wie sie
damit zurechtkommen wollen dass
Unternehmer mit selbstmorddrohen den sie
sagen ich weiß nicht ob ihr nächstes Gas
geben können ist nicht so als würden das
jetzt alle annehmen und sagen ist eine
großartige Lage aber diesen Strom dieses
strompreisproblem den lösen wir nicht
indem wir die atomkreis Problem
und ich meine das ist ein Problem über
dieser größte Industrienation der Welt
danke und die können sie eben
energiepolitisch nicht so steuern wie
ein Entwicklungsland wo sie sagen ja
also ob sie Strom bekommen oder nicht
das ähm steht in den Sternen so geht es
eben nicht also dann ist das eine enorme
standortbelastung wenn sie sagen die
ganzen Spitzen die wir dann ab bzw die
Täler die wir dann abfedern müssen das
machen wir über Abschaltung der
Industrie das Reden von 3 bis 12 Stunden
im Jahr wir reden von drei bis zwölf
Stunden an ein zwei Tagen im Februar
lautet
wir haben keine stromlänge Problem wir
haben ein netzstabilitätsproblem was ist
zu lösen und den Preisproblem haben wir
auf den Kunden
bei dem Thema kommen wir nicht mehr auf
allen grünen Zweig das wollen wir auch
gar nicht bei Final 8 streiten wir gerne
mal aber jetzt kommen wir zum Thema von
Herr Hank